programmes des différents partis
politique. Élisa Serret est allé
à leur rencontre.
- C'est à bord de son tracteur
que Philippe Beauregard
sillone ses champs
plusieurs fois par jour.
Car la vie de maraîcher
ne donne aucun répit. Surtout
avec les aléas de dame Nature.
PHILIPPE BEAUREGARD, Le potager
Mont-Rouge Halte Gourmande
- On parlait de changements
climatiques, là, bien,
maintenant, on est pris avec des
insectes. Ça bouge là-dedans.
- Chaque année, les changements
climatiques lui apportent
de nouveaux défis.
- Scarabées japonais,
ils doivent être 400-500.
- De nouveaux insectes,
de nouvelles maladies,
un réservoir d'eau souvent
à sec, des écarts de température
qui forcent son équipe
à travailler dans des
conditions souvent pénibles.
Sans compter les fruits et
légumes qui ne poussent plus
ou encore trop rapidement.
- On se ramasse avec
des citrouilles qui sont prêtes
trop tôt. C'est quand même
une problématique parce que
le marché primaire de
la citrouille est pour
les décorations d'Halloween.
Donc, cette année, on aurait pu
faire... j'avais proposé même
de faire l'Halloween le 31 août.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le mot d'ordre,
donc : s'adapter.
Avec son halte gourmande et
l'autocueillette, il peut vendre
des fruits et des légumes qui,
en raison des grandes chaleurs,
ne sont plus à la hauteur
de l'esthétisme requis
pour être vendus en épicerie.
Puis, le maraîcher
a dernièrement investi,
à grands frais, dans un immense
système de ventillation.
Il espère ainsi que
sa production reste fraîche
et qu'il trouvera des acheteurs
bientôt pour éviter
du gaspillage alimentaire.
- Tout ça apporte...
une série de questionnements,
à savoir est-ce qu'on continue
ou on arrête? On est tout
le temps aussi à se demander :
est-ce que c'est la fin? Est-ce
qu'on peut avoir une certaine
stabilité dans cette culture-là?
♪ ♪ ♪
- Et comme un défi n'attend pas
l'autre, avec la pandémie,
Philippe a eu de la difficulté
à faire venir ses travailleurs
étrangers. Ces travailleurs,
selon lui, assurent la sécurité
alimentaire au pays.
- S'ils étaient pas là,
il y aurait simplement aucun...
les étalages seraient vides dans
les supermarchés, c'est simple.
- La pandémie a démontré
l'importance de la sécurité
alimentaire au Canada.
Et pourtant, malgré
les événements liés
aux changements climatiques
des dernières années, les partis
en campagne ne semblent pas
en faire une priorité.
- On ne parle pas beaucoup
d'environnement relié à
l'agriculture dans à cette
période électorale et on n'en
parle pas de façon générale.
- Pascal Thériault croit
que des investissements en
recherche sont essentiels pour
l'agriculture et la sécurité
alimentaire, spécialement
en ces temps incertains.
PASCAL THÉRIAULT, agronome
et économiste, Université McGill
- C'est important d'investir
chez nos entreprises agricoles
plus conventionnelles, mais
il faut aussi donner une chance
aux petits entrepreneurs,
à toute cette commercialisation
par circuit court de vendre
direct, de pouvoir se déployer,
de pouvoir se développer,
parce que... elles constituent
un... un tissu... un filet
de sécurité important."
- Philippe est déçu de constater
que les chefs, en campagne,
ne voient pas l'urgence d'agir.
- Je suis un peu insulté de voir
la position des gouvernements
qui... mettent pas des points
sur les I, qui apportent pas
des actions concretes.
On voit les météos
qui sont chambranlantes,
qui vont d'un extrême
à l'autre, puis ça apporte
toutes sortes de problématiques
sur les producteurs agricoles.
- Malgré l'inquiétude,
Philippe est un grand passionné
et s'accroche aux petits côtés
positifs des variations
de températures.
- On va aller chercher
une racine. Et voilà!
- Les chaleurs intenses
des dernières années
lui permettent maintenant
faire pousser de l'ocra...
- Puis, on vient le manger.
- ... un légume qui, avant,
n'aimait pas les terres
québécoises.
- C'est vraiment